et sur les réseaux sociaux et sur nos
écrans connectés on retrouve aussi ce
dont on va parler maintenant avec vos
typhaine à savoir notre sélection livre
du jour qui concerne les jeunes et
aujourd'hui vous avez envie de jouer les
enquêtrices au surlendemain d'un
événement qui a eu lieu à beaune et dont
on a beaucoup parlé sur france3 fr oui
alors il ya eu le festival du film
policier abonné je me suis dit pour
notre première enquête nous pourrions
partir à la tour eiffel
oui parce que gustave eiffel et
dijonnais donc parts ont enquêté à la
tour eiffel avec ce petit livre qui a
démonté la tour eiffel c'est une enquête
de ninon par claudine aubrun et claudine
aubrun iq a écrit une série en fait avec
ce petit enquêteurs nino alors c'est un
petit garçon qui à chaque fois qu'il
croise quelqu'un d'un petit peu louche
se lance sur sa piste et mène l'enquêté
alors grâce à tous les membres de sa
famille à sa mamie sylvette ses parents
sa cousine et alors ce petit livre là
est très sympa je vous le conseille et
je vous conseille en fait toutes les
histoires de cette série puisque à
chaque fois ça permet de découvrir des
monuments historiques alors vous voyez
là c'est le château de versailles
ça permet aussi d'initier les lecteurs
des ce1 roman policier
et puis c'est un petit roman alors c'est
un format souple ça coûte seulement 3
euros est vraiment alors les polars mini
syros je vous les conseille
voilà ça mettre entre toutes les mains
et puis il ya plusieurs plusieurs
tranches d'âge alors ça c'est à partir
du ce1 mais vous avez aussi ce2 cm1 avec
des niveaux de langages un petit peu
différente donc c'est très sympa il ya
d'autres petits airs aux enquêteurs
qu'ils sont pas intéressants il ya même
beaucoup parce que cyrus en fait est
assez spécialisés finalement dans le
roman policier
et puis ça va jusque on va dire aux
adolescents et moi je voulais vous
parler d'une collection qu'ils ont qui
s'appelle type tongs journal ah oui
alors ça peut vous parler vous vous
sembler un peu bizarre mais alors celle
ci par exemple je vous donne cet exemple
là s'appelle mois détective in london le
journal de jeunes c'est aussi écrit par
claudine aubrun puisque apparemment elle
aime ça écrivent pour les enfants et ce
roman là et en anglais et en français
alors vous me direz comment c'est
possible d'écrire en anglais et en
français et bien il ya des partis qui
sont qui raconte l'histoire générale
en français et à l'intérieur il ya
énormément de mots de vocabulaire alors
ça peut être les jours les heures les
couleurs et puis on suit le récit en
anglais grâce à un fichier audio et en
même temps on peut et bien apprendre les
jours de la semaine alors c'est
accessible à partir du ce2 on va dire et
on peut grâce à tous les mots de
vocabulaire qui sont indiqués écrire son
propre journal comme si on était soit
même une petite enquêtrice ou un petit
enquêteurs à londres alors moi j'ai
trouvé ça très original dresse un pas et
en plus ça existe en espagnol et en
allemand
donc en fonction de ce qu'on a envie
d'apprendre à ses enfants
eh bien on peut leur proposer une
enquête est en plus l'apprentissage
d'une langue
d'accord la petite prévisions météo soit
de blue sky
en fait l'histoire si vous voulez choisi
un de ces mots de vocabulaire évidemment
puisqu'il peut pas faire le même temps
tous les jours mais vous après quand
vous écrivez votre journal quand vous
êtes en ce2 cm1 et bien vous pouvez
choisir en fait vos petits mots de
vocabulaire hellingly chauffe course est
bien évidemment forcément forcément si
après avoir appris l'anglais
tiphaine on veut mener notre propre
enquête où on veut faire mener à nos
enfants dans une petite enquête
vous avez des livres qu'il nous faut oui
et vous savez que j'aime bien vous
parlez cette maison d'édition bambou qui
est basée à mâcon ils ont une idée assez
sympa avec les énigmes les énigmes de
l'est à part nous de larbi est nouveau
alors chaque page fait une bande
dessinée chaque page vous propose une
enquête une énigme un petit mystère
qu'il va falloir résoudre
alors imaginons que un objet est disparu
comme ici c'est un portable qui
disparaît il faut trouver le coupable
alors dans chaque bus il ya peut-être un
petit indice ou bien dans les paroles de
la personne il faudrait deviner où est
le mensonge ou et l'incohérence alors le
lecteur lui doit deviner et léa elle
trouve à chaque fois évidemment vous ça
vous met un petit peu en difficulté que
ce soit en tant qu'enfant ou parfois
même en tant que parent alors les
enfants aiment bien défier les parents
évidemment
c'est sympa c'est accessible même aux
jeunes lecteurs
et puis c'est très ludique ça permet
aussi de faire travailler bien l'esprit
logique des enfants et puis vous voyez
c'est une bd dont c'est très sympa c'est
bien parce que les parents aussi la
croche voilà c'est ça donc ça permet
aussi de défier voilà les enfants ont
trouvé la réponse les parents sont un
peu en peine voilà c'est très sympa
c'est des histoires de voisinage de
querelles entre enfants voilà c'est
c'est vraiment bien fait et ça existe
aussi avec les énigmes de léo qu'il
aille se passe dans l'espace alors vous
choisissez soit vous aimez dans l'espace
ça vous restez dans la vie quotidienne
allez on va rester sur terre parce que
je crois que pour terminer vous nous
avez déniché des livres on va dire pour
les plus grands peut-être voilà c'est
plutôt à partir de 9 ans et là on est
dans le roman alors c'est du polar
fantastique comme à dire est ce que vous
connaissez la cia
oui alors par aux etats unis aussi
mais vous connaissez pas je pense
lagence pendergast n'en savait rien
alors la seconde a été rehaussée levées
non non ça veut dire quoi alors c'est
une agence qui a été fondée à la fin du
19e siècle au moment où il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui ont commencé à émigrer
aux états unis
et là on s'est rendu compte apparemment
tu y avait aussi des créatures
surnaturelles qui commençaient à fuir
l'europe voilà à cause des usines de
l'industrialisation et donc à quelqu'un
qui a eu l'idée de fonder une agence
pour les démasquer ellis island voilà
essayer de voir s'il avait peint ou de
vampires qui se cachait parmi ces
nouveaux arrivants et c'est donc le
principe de cette histoire écrite par
christophe lambert et publié par didier
jeunesse
alors je vous la conseille c'est très
sympa on découvre voilà toutes ces
créatures surnaturelles qui se déguisent
pour essayer de passer la frontière
donc c'est à la fois un polar est une
histoire fantastique je pense que ça
plaira aux lecteurs à partir de 9 ans et
le super typhon nesat sélection livres
pour enfants à retrouver sur le net et
les réseaux sociaux pendant quemener vis
à vis tranquille de chiens à adopter se
précise sur ce plateau ce matin